so I am going to start the meeting are
we all set Christina
all right good afternoon everybody this
is a forgotten meeting this is a meeting
on Bill's uh retained for intermerm
study that your chair forgot completely
about until she was reminded by the
clerk via our assistant so we had to
schedule this meeting for today at three
o'clock so I want to thank everybody for
coming in the committee retained two
bills
um for interim study HB 51 which was a
portioning state senate districts and HB
apportioning executive council districts
so in regards to those bills I would
like to address here for executive
session the first bill of HB
51 is there a motion yes Madam chair
Representative Steve Smith I move that
HB 51 not be recommended for future
legislation
is there a second I'll second that Madam
representative Bergeron second simotion
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Smith in a sense since we
do have to write a report which has
graciously been provided how about I
the committee recommends that House Bill
51 not be introduced as written or as
might be otherwise proposed the bill
proposed redistricting of the state
senate districts the committee
recommended interim study to provide a
vehicle for a redistricting plan should
another plan fail
State Senate districts have been adopted
and have been implemented for the 2022
election this bill is not necessary end
of report
is there any further discussion
seeing none I'm going to ask the clerk
okay Representative Steven Smith yes
yes
representative McDonald votes yes
representative Lynn yes
representative Berry yes
representative O'Hara
representative haken Phillips
yes
representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative Bergeron yes
representative Lane
yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Wilhelm yes
12 in favor and three no votes
thank you
um so HB 51 will be reported out as not
recommended for further legislation the
next bill that we have to consider it
Representatives Marjorie Smith
foreign
it's just there is 12-0 it's twelve
okay
it would not have been 12
. there are three no votes as in silent
votes
the ballot was not even picked up never
mind cast all right the next bill to be
considered is HB 53 HB 53 is in regards
to apportioning executive council
districts is anyone interested in making
a motion on HB 53 yes Madam chair
representative Smith I move that house
bill 53 not be recommended for future
legislation
is there a second representative
Bergeron's second thing yes
Representatives Smith would you like to
speak to your motion yes the committee
recommends that house bill 53 not be
introduced as written or as might be
otherwise proposed this bill proposed
redistricting of the state's executive
council districts the committee
recommended interim study to provide a
vehicle for a redistricting plan should
another plan fail executive council
districts have been adopted and have
been implemented for the 2022 election
this bill is not necessary end report
is there any further discussion on HP 53
seeing none I'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
representative Stephen Smith yes
representative Stapleton yes
representative turcotte
representative McDonald votes yes
representative Lynn yes
representative Berry yes
representative O'Hara
representative haken Phillips
yes
representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative Bergeron yes
representative Lane yes
representative Piedra
representative Horrigan yes
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Griffin yes
12-0 thank you very much
that concludes our business for today's
meeting I think we beat the over under
at 10 minutes and I would like to point
out that the redistricting committee has
finished with a unanimous vote please
so there you go this meeting is
adjourned